scorpion displayed many characteristics
of a full Pharaoh but he came from an
earlier age archeologists had just
opened a door on a whole new chapter of
Egyptian history finding these objects
was an amazing sensation because it was
just so new and different things like
the Scorpion may said radically change
people's perceptions they took them back
to a time for which they had no texts it
was really there were flummox they
didn't know what to do I think that's
why there's been so much interest in the
name it was a bit of writing that they
could read at the time it was widely
assumed that Egyptian civilization
sprang up suddenly in around 3,000 BC
with the arrival of the first Pharaohs
many people had thought it had to be an
invasion of a superior race the
exquisite beauty of the things that the
Egyptian civilization created at the
turn of the century people didn't want
to believe this was coming out of Africa
they wanted to root it in Mesopotamia or
even in Europe in some ways it was quite
racist few Egyptologists questioned the
accepted idea that the pharaohs were
foreign invaders bringing rapid progress
to a backward country but with quibbles
discovery of a king who predated the
Pharaohs cracks began to appear in this
theory the history books were about to
be rewritten